hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic guy
remember it so you don't have to and I'm
still continuing the month of nostalgia
week what the hell's wrong with me so
see how this is the month where
everything is supposed to be scary let's
take a look at scary performances we all
know the traditional monsters and how
iconic they've become but a new breed of
monsters has been evolving over the
years they constantly battle between
what's human what's inhuman and usually
the more remove they are from an ethical
reality the more frightening they become
now keep in mind I know a good
performance isn't just a good
performance a lot of things go into it
like the rioting directing music
lighting all the good stuff but still
these are the characters and
performances we're just thinking about
them can send shivers down our spines
and we're here to honor the top eleven
of them here today why top 11
number one
Bill Sikes from Oliver this guy is just
a bastard he does it all
kidnapped kids steals from the wealthy
and even beats his own girlfriend one of
the main characters in the film to death
what a fucked up creep she would become
nobody now and every time you look at
him you know he's ready to strike again
he doesn't care who gets in his way if
you say something wrong your ass is
going down you hand it over you ever
wish a sope skin it even with that thick
cockney accent he still scares the
living piss out yet have you ever heard
the song the chicken makes when they
were ringing off its name a school
spiking they school not a very pretty
song hello he can even make the act of
calling his dog seem intimidating you I
crazy Leo he push on you come here
coming out Oh God you can just tell
actor Oliver Reeve was throwing
everything into it and because then we
get one hell of a creepy thug Bill Sikes
is definitely one Betty who will do
anything to get his way number 10
the t1000 from Terminator 2 I know a lot
of people found Arnold to be pretty
scary in the first Terminator but let's
be honest it's still Arnold he looks
like a giant robot talks like a giant
robot so it's pretty easy to guess that
he's a giant robot as well as easy to
spot in a crowd with Robert Patrick
though he looks like any other person
and can even act like an everyday guy
blending into the crowd with nobody
suspecting him I just thought he was
going to the gallery right the Galleria
but when he needs to kill good God
nothing can stop he can turn into knives
he can turn into other people he can
imitate their voices and plus he's a cop
as if to say even the fucking police are
after your kid you don't have a prayer
call to John on top of that he's chasing
a child in this one which seems much
more vulnerable than chasing a grown
woman grandi he's a strong kid but he's
still a kid and this is as basic a
boogeyman as you can come up with you
can reason with him you can't hurt him
and all he wants to do is kill you if
that's not scary as fuck
I don't know what
that's a nice play
number nine
any whips from misery the role that one
kathy bates and oscar this psychotic
bitches 32 flavors are crazy
she helps save the life of her favorite
author in the world and then goes crazy
when she finds out he's killing off her
favorite character she strapped into a
bed breaks both of his legs and forces
him to write a sequel to the book where
misery had brought back god i love you
if that wasn't freaky enough she
constantly swings back and forth between
sensitive and kind you've got a lot of
recovering to do and i consider it an
honor that you'll do it in my home drink
to know back actually for me the
screaming and yelling parts always seem
a bit over the top it's when she was
nice and pleasant that really got me on
edge but maybe that's because i know
that anything could set her off
oh what a poet you are oh well isn't she
just the nicest yeah yeah your life i
think this is every celebrities worst
nightmare to be in the hands of an
obsessive fan who's not mentally well i
mean poor james caan god japp has a lot
to deal with in this movie but hey look
at the bright side at least we're
casting about Schmidt oh no doubt about
it and he will tis one nutty lady that
nobody should have to wake up to hey
number
Hannibal Lecter now I'm just going to be
very honest about this I never really
found Hannibal Lecter in Silence of the
Lambs that's scary actually thought
Buffalo Bill was a lot scarier because
he actually seemed like a real-life
serial killer for me Hannibal Lecter was
more like a James Bond villain he had
all the poetic lines keeping his head
down with an evil smile all I was
missing was a cat fur and a stroke I
wouldn't really mind except that the
rest of the movie is so bent up being
brutally realistic and for me this kind
of seems out of place you fly back to
school now it was Donnie come on that's
pretty silly now granted the first time
you see him is pretty damn creepy just
how I was standing in the middle of the
room like he can smell her coming down
the hallway that's unsettling but
there's just a ham enos to this
performance that always sort of rubbed
me the wrong way you're funny
so yeah I bashed him so much you're
probably wondering why the hell do I
even put him on this list well to be
honest I thought he was scary and red
dragon yeah I know he's like a bajillion
years old and that's really distracting
but in this movie I find him more scary
because he actually wants to get Edward
Norton and figures out ways from inside
his cell to try and hurt it that's
freaky as hell you can lock him up and
he can still get you insides of the
Lambs I knew he wasn't going to attack
Jodie Foster in fact she even mentions
it at some point he won't come after me
oh really
I won't I can't explain a hate D he
would consider that rude but in red
dragon he fucking hates this guy and
even behind a glass wall he can still
find a way to attack both him and his
family that's diabolical it's like
there's no way to stop him
roof can fall on anybody but not on
Molly
they're safe now no one will ever be
safe around you well
I also like the fact that's much more a
challenge of wins in Silence of the
Lambs foster just sort of looks at
Leonards antics with frightened aww in
red dragon Norton doesn't take any of
that shit do you dream much will by dr.
Lecter give me the file then I'll tell
you what I think this makes the
relationship more interesting to me it
just builds up the tension between the
two
it makes the hero more interesting and
the villain more angry which in turn
makes him more threatening now I will
say though a lot of people argue that's
much more threatening when an evil
person loves you as opposed to hates you
and to be honest I can see how that
would be pretty scary too so in this
category I'm saying Hannibal Lecter from
both the Silence of the Lambs and red
dragon or on the list and for those of
you wondering why I didn't put Hannibal
I'm there the brain and the stage that
was stupid and anybody who likes it is
stupid too I know it's just my opinion
but I'm right and a nice Chianti Marisa
Alex from A Clockwork Orange it's hard
to believe that not only is this crazy
team supposed to only be in high school
but we're also supposed to oddly enough
identified with him after all what's not
identifiable about murder rape beatings
Breaking and Entering and being a
complete psychotic nut ball what was
that great big ol seek gape of a green
ball damn the kid is a sadist plain and
simple
he's not in it for the money or any kind
of physical reward for the most part
he's in it because he simply loves to do
wrong and sees almost an artistic life
to it all oh please bliss and heaven oh
it was gorgeousness and gorgeo Satine
made flesh he's a savage beast but he
listens to Beethoven he feeds on the
innocent but is still intelligent and
well-spoken we've seen smart villains
before but what really separates him
from other villains is two things one is
his age the idea that a person this
young would be doing so many terrible
things is pretty disturbing the second
is just how much he enjoys it the smile
on his face is just pure delight he is
in heaven there is no remorse on what he
is doing for him causing people pain is
like reaching Nirvana nirvana on a
roller coaster he simply loves every
minute of it to a point where he
actually hums singing in the rain while
raping an older woman this scene is so
traumatizing that there's still people
out there who can't listen to that music
yes one of the most controversial
characters in both film and literature
Alex is one of the scariest school
children you'll ever come across I told
you much my little droogies
number six
Norman Bates from psycho you have
another character who just sort of keeps
you guessing and guessing he can't
figure out if he's a good guy a bad guy
and innocent pawn or an evil plotter all
you know is that he's horribly obsessed
with his mother and the less you know
about that the better
did you go out with friends well I'm a
boy's best friend is his mother every
time you see him you get nervous you
can't tell if he's just a poor soul or
time bomb waiting to go off we all go a
little mad sometimes his twitching and
sudden mood swings keeps the character a
complete mystery until the very end and
without actually giving away the twist
ending let's just say every movie
nowadays that does have a twist ending
owes everything to this film I
understand
I don't hate her I hate what she's
become if you haven't seen the movie yet
check it out and see how influential
both the film and his performance ones
and speaking of influences what do you
think Alec's got his smile from but
she's harmless
she's as harmless as one of those
stuffed birds oh and if you're thinking
about seeing the shot-by-shot remake i
have only one thing to say Vince Vaughn
as Norman Bates
number five
the Gemini killer from Exorcist 3 this
film is sort of like the Planet of the
Apes movies if you can by the absurdity
of it all it's actually a pretty damn
good film you just really got to stretch
your suspension of disbelief and one of
the things that makes it so effective is
Brad Dourif
and Jason Miller as the Gemini killer
sort of a long story but after the death
of Damian in the first Exorcist movie
another spirit known as the Gemini
killer sneaks in there for we sometimes
see the person as Damian
or as the killer and both are pretty
damn scary Jason Miller does well
switching personalities and is suffering
over there they can be cruel who is they
never mind
do that brother well don't you think
well Brad Dourif does well actually
being one of the personalities
do you dance freely both range from
gentle whispers to blood-curdling
screams never knowing what's going to
come out of them in the tube moves
through the vein under the crease of the
arm as he watches wow I laugh and cut
and you like the innocent his friends
and again and again he is inside with us
he will never get away his pain Walden
the film was directed by the author of
the original Exorcist book and he
certainly shows an understanding of both
suspense and horror is it as good as the
first film no can it be far-fetched
sometimes but it still a really creepy
and nerve tingling movie with haunting
visuals creepy ideas and of course too
great performances as the Gemini killer
come in father morning bender night
this time you're going to lose
No
the Joker from The Dark Knight it's
almost pointless to talk about this
performance as I've talked about so much
but I think everybody was taken back at
just how terrifying he Ledger was as the
Joker we know nothing about his past
family or friends we just know that his
goal is to simply spread chaos introduce
a little energy upset the established
order everything becomes chaos
he's like a demon that can't be
destroyed but the most disturbing part
is he makes it sound like he shouldn't
be destroyed like he's part of the grand
plan he makes it sound like it's the
natural order that he's Humanity fully
realized when the chips are down these
civilized people they'll eat each other
see I'm not a monster
I'm just ahead of the curve we don't
know if he was born that way or had to
go through some sort of crazy series of
events but either way he's bad news
both Ledger and Nolan took what was
primarily an old-school comic book
villain and turned him into the
embodiment of anarchy and chaos but
there's hints of a dark reality that
lies in him too and I think that's where
the real fear comes from I think we can
all agree the scariest scene is the one
that seen the most realistic as the
shaky camera and the bad audio truly
added to the grittiness of this murder
scene combining the dark side of comics
with the dark side of reality the Joker
is one evil clown we will soon be
forgetting hi so serious
number three
anton from no country for old men it was
actually pretty hard deciding who was
creepier anton oh the joker I decided to
go with Anton for one main reason
unlike the Joker who wants to be anarchy
and misery I think Anton feels he has to
be anarchy and misery like there's no
other choice that's just another level
of depression to add to this character
you don't have to do this people always
say the same thing what did they say
they say you don't have to do this he
doesn't really smile in life so he's not
fully enjoying what he's doing it's like
a strange fixation that if he doesn't do
certain horrible things the world will
be thrown out of alignment what to like
the Joker we don't know why he's come to
this conclusion but it's pretty obvious
nobody's changing his mind you just look
at him and you think unpleasantness how
does he see the world where he feels he
has to do these things I won't tell you
you can save yourself because he can't
full movie itself is basically about the
evolution of the dark criminal mind and
how it's only getting worse
evolving to a point where not only can
we not control it but even more
disturbing we can't understand it Anton
is the perfect representation of that
not feeling never satisfied doesn't know
if he's doing the right thing or the
wrong thing but above all doesn't care
every word he says is beyond cryptic as
well as confusing you got no cause to
hurt me but I gave my word your husband
they don't make sense I mean one has a
coin toss ever been so fucking
terrifying
I don't think so a little bit but this
still takes the cake just going I didn't
put nothin oh yes you did you've been
putting it up your whole life you just
didn't know it I need to know what I
stand to win everything just tend to win
everything call it
everything has a meaning but everything
also means nothing total shit your pants
philosophy come put it in your pocket
and you're like Atwater what a little
bit mixed in with the others and
becoming just a coin which it is Anton
says stranger you hope never to meet in
the middle of nowhere who is it
you know who it is number two
Ragan from The Exorcist considered to be
the scariest movie of all time The
Exorcist all centers around a girl who's
possessed by something not of this world
is it the devil maybe is it one of its
followers who knows but one thing we can
figure out is that Regan is not alone
when is Regan in here with us on top of
Linda Blair's fantastic performance we
also have the voice talent of Mercedes
McCambridge who has one of those creepy
voices where you can't really tell if
it's a man or a woman which just makes
it all the more surreal how long are you
planning to stay in Regan until she rots
and I stinking in the earth on top of
that the makeup the lighting in the
overall direction makes the idea of a
possessed girl seem surprisingly
plausible am i they shake your leash
guys do you like leave a message
I see vacation you really feel like
you're there as all the shit is going on
and so did a lot of other people
apparently audience members went
streaming out of the theaters when they
first saw this film and even today they
continued to show it in theaters around
Halloween why because it still gets a
shock out of people I'm Damian come and
I got gamma now kindly undo they stretch
this little demon brat was scary back
then and is still scary now she had
everything a spinning head Green vomit
telekinesis voices she could imitate
shape-shifting she had it all and I
guess she might have been a murderer too
but I don't know is the idea when father
Merrin has found dead they died over a
heart attack or the Reagan killer if she
killed him how exactly did that work hey
father look over there alright
whatever happened there's certainly no
doubt that little Reagan definitely had
more than one person in her head
and the number one scariest performance
is
hell from 2001 a Space Odyssey why
because he's everything inspiring and
terrifying about the evolution of man
he's the supreme computer as artificial
intelligence and can come to logical
conclusions on his own I would recommend
that we put the unit back in operation
and let it fail we can certainly afford
to be out of communication for the short
time it will take to replace it but with
that comes a thinking that only runs on
logic and when the computer sees the
crew of the ship as a danger to the
mission he destroys them no second
thoughts
he just destroys them during the past
few weeks I've wondered whether you
might be having some second thoughts
about the mission there's no sympathy no
reasoning just logic open the pod bay
doors help I'm sorry then I'm afraid I
can't do that this mission is too
important for me to allow you to
jeopardize everything he says no matter
how creepy is always in that monotone
voice it's never happy sad or angry it's
not like a person where you can argue to
their emotional side with hell you know
there's no emotional side if he thinks
you should go you're gone and he'll use
everything that mankind has programmed
into him to carry it out this
conversation can serve no purpose
anymore goodbye the other creepy thing
is how knows about the human animal and
does everything he can to trick them
like pretending he can't hear them in
the space pod when he's secretly reading
their lips or how about when he tries to
play today's emotional side by flat-out
lying to him I know everything hasn't
been quite right with me I feel much
better now
I really do he'll do anything to
complete the mission and what makes him
so scary is that we designed him that
way we have nobody to blame but us in
many ways he's the ultimate
accomplishment but in others he's the
ultimate fuckup we can't blame him
because we'd be blaming ourselves and
the sinister determination that Hal has
is a direct representation of what we
pride efficiency at any cost
it can only be attributable to human
error this sort of thing is cropped up
before and it has always been due to
human error hell is scary because of his
voice is actions and most of all where
he came from us he's a cautionary tale
if not only where mankind could be going
but what we can have and will ultimately
become and those are my top 11 scariest
performances and for those of you
wondering why I did put Tim Curry from
it on there don't worry enlighten it
will be coming next week
they see